[Music]
if you like pizza and you enjoy pizza
and you eat pizza the like load is
extremely high that you have seen our
pizza boxes my name is Gil Curran and I
make pizza boxes for a living we roughly
make 10 million boxes a week as far as
design is concerned it's very particular
you know picture of a pizza box kind of
like an album used to be it kind of
creates what the artist is all about and
that's what you know these owners view
their pizza boxes that I've probably
done over 10,000 designs this is a
Hawley original and it's everywhere I
see it in the garbage pails I see it on
the side of the Parkway I see it at
friends houses when they get pizza the
fact that so many people literally
millions of people have seen my work and
don't know that it's me it kind of makes
me chuckle to myself like I'm somehow
sneaking through life with this identity
that no one knows having started the
business from the beginning the one
thing about pizza it brings happiness to
everybody everyone loves pizza
[Music]
this is pizza
now before you pizza purist destroys in
the comments please open your mind and
let me explain this is Zanzibar Pizza
[Music]
many people in the only law Italian
pizza we call it as my pizza because of
the materials because other materials is
only from saspa like Italian it is about
it is same same but different meet
Muhammad he is the best pizza maker in
Zanzibar and is pretty well known around
his hometown famous it was I making a
tasty pizza also because I would smile
and thought oh I didn't know I was with
a celebrity
I will kill pizza Master Chef master
pizza anyway Mohammed is a fixture at
the for Adani garden night market making
pizza both sweet and savory for over 10
years
they make a definite dia type of Pisa
like the Pentium or more than 20 every
morning Muhammed goes to the local
market for the very best and fresh
ingredients in order to make his
one-of-a-kind homemade Zanzibar pizza
pies after that I take in my chopped
chopped vegetable i Quixote only green
pepper fresh tomato and then I mix the
center then I put the MRIs cheese and
egg then I take the beef with a my
spiced masala and then I mix together
and then I close for all sides I take it
then I put for the BBQ the dough
presence of our pizza is actually
chapati and
and bread which is also made by hand I
take my flour and the otter I mix only
flour in Georgia after that I've got the
ball
big and small I make like a small
chapati because he's like he supported
and helped me to carry pizza to put for
the power cube e that sounds good
Kosmic is like the best in the world
I feel happy because they yum-yum TomTom
and that my friends is pizza zanzibar
pizza
[Music]
does pineapple belong on pizza okay stop
Sweden cease your pineapple and raises
you banana on pizza curry on pizza and
kebab on pizza
seriously Sweden so let's forget about
pineapple because here in Sweden they
have a completely different take on
pizza here it's a pizza topping free for
all my med has been cooking pizzas for
25 years and he will tell you anything
goes
things like banana banana it'sa the yet
devotee a shaker hell rock so net the
special prevented moon day at the
Burnham and Anna's curry so what are the
sweets eat in the summer the huorchi bar
patrons from heaven mama Mia
after milega festival food an oven
Malaga rose vessel and roll egg rotten
water or pepperoni two witnesses or
resource lead esta then see if they're
wrong I mean who doesn't love a kebab so
ocean of la pasta pizzeria what's on
your menu vehicle Brad Corbin on 30 or
company owner shrimp
Oh st. so Sweden oh there's more there's
curry pizza which is chicken banana
curry and pineapple or my favorite
Tropicana ham banana and Renee's mmm
this isn't just a late-night snack is it
Nirvana Toscana shop it's Italian the
gamma ray with the festive ROTC and so
on partner
polka treaded on Neela we want our pizza
at the Embassy me now for the real
question why did Sweden reinvent an
already perfect food diet monado
experimenter otoscope agravada blandina
so they made a small trade he says kebab
on pizza and Rahil Bono's I think you
come the leg up on my pizza some amana's
so what the end I only smoked it and now
the most important part that tastes
[Music]
really good India Theresa he need owner
Victoria in a peter savio vega yogacara
okay Pocono my example I read Alec
quickly and there in the center Havana
there's a pair of entrepreneurs or
taking pizza delivery to new heights
yo so Martha uno la magia earmark ro
llama ho
[Music]
know how I am what I saw a principal
Ohama polical era la SOTA hace con la
pieza caminando no cancel amo mucho y la
gente no way on the day they're issued
really they're taken a SATA Mahila piece
for a backbone 2010 month the number one
and her husband were granted a private
business license and open up a pizzeria
a few months ago her husband passed away
now her best friend is helping her keep
the pizzeria alive I mean Juanita for
you today Lovisa a la moneda suya me
nosotros a lemon since then the pizzeria
which operates her martin number ones
roof has filled countless stomachs with
their secret recipe primera vez esta in
la maza en la salsa
it can't be severed initial prosthetic
abyssal ssssso manera a own knowledge in
sacred SOC a mantra doggie Mantegna me
moti poem nasa again a massive manual la
carrera Chrissa in decoding I meant I
wanna give you a hint at de playa the
municipio player and idea Albuquerque's
now Pisa
are you a Kwan Buchta you are I enter
Sony videos Rivera ever since Martin
number to join Martin number one in
business to have formed a true
partnership
I don't matter - a cookie cutter I don't
matter point omikuji decision
okay fantasy me or Maranello CEO seemed
a threat OSL oppose arena arena Nana so
the bouquet bouquet released at the
Alaric DF it has on recent DNA dreaming
Diwali people may not think pizza
tossing is a serious sport it really is
it's a lot of hard work
[Music]
my name is Tony Gemignani and I'm a
12-time world pizza champion I have two
Guinness Book of World Records one for
most consecutive rolls across the
shoulders in 30 seconds it was 36 rolls
across the shoulders 36 or 37 yeah we'll
say 37 so Pizza acrobatics are tricks
with pizza dough a lot of people ask me
you know pizza throwing how do you
describe it it's kind of like oh what a
Harlem Globetrotter does with a
basketball but we do with the pizza you
know around the back across the
shoulders through the legs two at a time
on the ground spinning in your hands the
difference between you know a basketball
and a pizza hit misshapes it gets bigger
and gets softer not like it's juggling
balls that are always the same it's
pretty magical so every year in Las
Vegas there's Pizza Expo and the Pizza
Expo there's a world Pizza games when
you walked it out with stage there's
acrobats from all around the world
competing they'll be getting judged by a
panel of three to five judges and those
judges will look for dexterity
creativity difficulty and as they're
judging them they'll look for drops and
they'll look for transitions from trick
to trick there's about a two to three
minute routine in music they have to
nail it they've been practicing all year
for it there's a trick in the sport
called the Gemignani my last name it's a
trick that I did it's two across the
shoulders and you catch it
nobody loves pizza more than me even I
have on my chest it's a pizza for life
[Music]
you